well good afternoon ladies and gentlemen
I'm Brad Thompson and I have the
distinct honor to be the executive
director of the Clemson Institute for
the Study of capitalism it is my
pleasure to welcome you here this
afternoon to our John W Pope lecture
series this event is being live-streamed
and I would also like to welcome our
livestream audience from around the
world before we begin today's events I'd
like to take this opportunity to thank
publicly the sponsors of this event the
John W Pope Foundation has generously
supported this lecture series for a
decade I'd also like to thank our
co-sponsors the ein Rand Institute and
the Rubin report just a word quickly
about the iron Rand Institute it
promotes the works of iron Rand and her
philosophy objectivism the philosophy of
reason rational self-interest and
individualism it has distributed
millions of copies of rands novels
anthem The Fountainhead and Atlas
Shrugged to teachers and students and it
runs one of the world's largest essay
contests and now a word about the
Clemson Institute for the Study of
capitalism the Clemson Institute is
America's first and best-known academic
center dedicated to exploring the moral
foundations of a free society and it is
Clemson's premier academic center
providing students with a great books
education in philosophy literature and
politics our Lyceum Scholars Program is
now recognized as one of the most
innovative and important undergraduate
programs in the United States as many of
you know free thought and free speech
are under assault on America's college
campuses I would like to remind the
students here with us today that the
Clemson Institute for the Study of
capitalism stands Foursquare in defense
of your freedom of thought and speech
and now to our main event let me
introduce our panelists Dave Rubin
sitting in the middle is a talk-show
host comedian and TV personality the
host of the popular YouTube talk show
the Rubin report Dave regularly
addresses big ideas such as free speech
political correctness and religion among
many other high-profile guests on his
show dave has interviewed sam Harris
ayaan Hirsi Ali
Larry elder and maybe most importantly
Clemson's very own professor Brandon
Turner dr. Jordan Peterson sitting
closest to me has been in his life a
dishwasher gas jockey bartender
short-order cook beekeeper oil derrick
bit rita / plywood mill laborer railway
line worker a clinical psychologist and
a consultant to the UN secretary-general
in more recent years he took a demotion
to be a professor of psychology at
Harvard University and now at the
University of Toronto he is the author
of the now classic book maps of meaning
the architecture of belief in this
January he will publish 12 rules for
life an antidote to chaos for those of
you who follow dr. Peterson on YouTube
you know that he has become something of
an academic rockstar in recent years and
is considered by many maybe me most of
all to be one of America's most
influential public intellectuals and dr.
got a sitting on the far side is a
senior fellow and a philosopher in
residence at the eyeing Rand Institute
in California he has taught philosophy
for over 10 years at the Institute
subjectivist academi
Center and he has published several
essays on rands fiction and philosophy
dr. got a is one of the world's leading
scholars of Iran's philosophy and he is
a contributing author to the Institute's
most recent book defending free speech
ladies and gentlemen please join me in
giving a Rosen and I mean a rousing
Clemson welcome to our panelists
all right we will accept that as rousing
are you sure are you guys there right
with that for rousing I was a little
worried at first because when he said
free speech and we got like one clap
over there you guys were kind of looking
away for free speech we are this is a
we're for it I'm very excited to be here
I was wandering around campus all day
long I don't know if you guys are
following me on Twitter I saw a squirrel
outside the library garbage can eating
an Oreo and I walk around for another
hour and then he was eating another Oreo
when I came back I thought there's
something special happening here at
Clemson so I'm very excited there's
squirrels eating Oreos we got these guys
they know their stuff where's Morgan by
the way who I was tweeting with earlier
where's Morgan Morgan over there she
normally only wears sorority shirts and
Nike shorts but she dressed up in
regular people clothes to be here that's
pretty good give her a round of applause
I also was gonna wear a sorority shirt
and shorts but then they made me put
this on I'm very excited to talk to you
guys we've got about an hour and a half
which I know is gonna fly by the
university the administration was great
too because we're doing a free speech
thing here and they gave me a list of
topics we're allowed to talk about so
let's see what we can find
oh by the way I also I saw that outside
there were a couple Nazis out there so
thank you for those who that punched
them because you got to be punching
Nazis just just joke people there were
no Nazis outside
I know Twitter's ablaze right now oh god
you heard Rubin the Nazis showed up all
right okay we're going to talk about
free speech and and we want this to be a
conversation so we're gonna do about
forty five and then you guys will jump
in with a Q&A at the end of that so I
think first off to kick this thing off
the fact that we even have to do talks
about free speech these days seems sort
of tragically ironic or hilarious or
depressing depending on which way you
want to look at it but anything that
we're gonna say up here I'm pretty sure
you're not gonna hear anything racist
then you're not gonna hear anything
homophobic or I mean I'm gay married I'm
not even gay I just did it to prove a
point and what you are gonna hear is
people expressing their views and that
is simply the most important thing that
you can do as a college student that you
guys get to not only learn from great
people one of them sitting right there
and a dad mom I show but you you get to
express what you think and learn how to
think and these two gentlemen are quite
good at explaining how they think so
first Jordan I'll start with you the
fact that we even have to do this that
that we can't do a talk perhaps
on maps of meaning although that's going
to be sort of part of what you talked
about that we have to talk about free
speech in and of itself does that sort
of show you what a precarious position
it's in well I think what it shows me is
just exactly how powerful ideas are you
know and people have the misbegotten
notion that the strange things that are
happening in our societies in Canada in
North America in the Western world in
general are somehow academic issues that
only affect people in colleges and
universities and nothing could be
farther from the truth than that you
know it's just that the wars between
different sets of ideas manifest
themselves first in the colleges and the
universities before they when they're
way out into the general public and this
is a war of ideas at an extraordinarily
deep level it's it's not political it's
not philosophical even I think it's
really at the level of religious thought
which is one level below one say one
it's the substructure of philosophical
thought in some sense and it has to do
with the place that is deemed
appropriate for the individual versus
the group in in the world in being
itself and the postmodern claim
postmodern neo-marxist claim let's say
because there's an unholy alliance
between those two branches of
pathological thought in my estimation
their conclusion is is that the
individual is first of all nothing but a
concatenation of cultural and biological
forces with with heavy emphasis on the
cultural no real capacity for free will
no separate identity from the group
identity and and therefore really of
little value or merit or significance
and to me that's an Emma I think I
pronounced that right I've probably only
read it but because the West is founded
on the principle that the individual is
sovereign and that is not a trivial idea
it means that we've recognized and and
much death went into this realization
that's the thing that's important to
under
Stan we've realized that states that are
not in the final analysis subordinate to
the to the spiritual and intellectual
supremacy of the free individual are
doomed to dissolution or tyranny and I
think that it is it's very difficult to
make a stronger moral and philosophical
claim than that one now it's a
frightening claim because it means that
each individual is a value and also that
what the individual does matters and
that's actually quite a terrifying
proposition because it means that your
moral errors actually have some
ontological weight I would say they
actually affect the structure of reality
itself in a profound manner and to
contemplate that deeply especially in
the light of the horrors say that
individual actions allowed or
contributed to in the 20th century is a
very terrifying proposition so this is
no lightweight this is no realm of
lightweight consideration but make no
mistake about it we're in one vicious
war about the structure of reality and I
hope that the classic virtues and values
are are able to organize themselves and
articulate themselves so that young
people can understand what they are and
so that this thing can turn out properly
so yeah well I think talking about this
in the frame of a war is sort of an
interesting way because it seems to me
we've chatted with about thirty students
earlier today and what everything seems
to be coming back to is about learning
how to think so that you don't have to
silence your opponents and it seems that
this is the place right this is the
place where you guys are right now this
is the place where you're supposed to
learn how to think so that if someone
says something that is counter to what
you believe that you now can think your
way out of it show them what the truth
is what has happened to that the ability
to know what you think and
own your own mind yeah I mean I think
that goes to the the initial question
you were asking of is in aren't we in a
weird circumstance now that no one is
really on the side or very few people on
the side of free speech but if you go
Jordan brought up which I think is
really important ideas of powerful so if
you look historically authorities have
tried to control ideas because they're
so powerful most societies have never
had freedom of speech and even when you
look in the West I mean the first
comprehensive philosopher Plato has a
system in which you don't have freedom
of speech and it's because he doesn't
think most people can reason they're not
autonomous in that kind of way so he has
it philosopher Kings who were at the top
they can think they can reason so they
have full freedom but the people
underneath don't and it was a radical
idea that came as a result of the
Enlightenment I think of that know the
individual each individual has within
and the power to control their own mind
to direct their own thinking and to
reach knowledge so just as it was a
radical idea in the way the American
founders framed it of the pursuit of
happiness there's also the issue of the
pursuit of truth and that each
individual is capable of doing that he
might default he might not really be
pursuing that but he's capable of doing
that but the only way that he can do
that is if he's free and that means no
authorities hemming him in and telling
him you can't look at that you can't
hear this person you can't investigate
this in the way they tried to hem in
Galileo and say no you cannot do this
you're under house arrest no more
investigation you have to be free to do
that but you have to have to really
value free speech you have to have this
view of yourself that I'm capable of
doing this I'm worthy of doing this and
I demand my freedom and I'm not gonna
submit to any authority telling me what
to do and even like if you put an Albert
Einstein like Plato's idea of a
philosopher or a king at the top of
government I would not submit to him
telling me well don't look at Holocaust
deniers because it's all irrational I
think it is all irrational but I need to
make up that opinion or
for myself if I want to look and read
some Holocaust deniers I want I have to
be free to do that
to look at and say oh no this is all
garbage it's all rational I won't look
at so it comes from a real the value of
free speech comes from a conception of
yourself as a pursuer of truth and I
think the postmodernist so I called the
anti enlightenment crowd or driving into
people that you're not capable of that
and you won't value free speech if you
really think you're not capable yes so
really knowing what you think and why
you think it is is really the key to
this whole operation it's interesting
you brought up Holocaust deniers we we
did an event a couple months back at
University of Arizona and I looked in
the crowd and I saw a diverse the
diversity that the left loves I saw a
diversity of color and sexuality and all
that stuff and I said that's not really
the diversity that I care about I care
about diversity of thought I said well
for example how many Nazis are here and
actually someone in the back raised
their hand and said that they were a
Nazi and and then they started going on
about Holocaust and I said you know what
hang tight we'll honor some free speech
when we get to the Q&A we'll give you
the first question so then we got to the
Q&A and I threw it to her and she was
going on and on about Auschwitz whatever
I had Michael Shermer was there who I'm
sure many of you guys know from skeptic
magazine and he debunks a lot of this
stuff and he clearly explained to her
why she was wrong now of course she
doesn't come around no one's gonna come
around but I thought it was a great
example of what free speeches that we
let her share her ideas everyone in the
audience kind of looked at her like this
is nutty and we we honored free speech
an interesting little caveat to this as
I mentioned to you guys earlier she was
trans which is kind of how often you
meet a trans Holocaust denier that was
that was pretty good you know that was
something Hitler loved those trans
people didn't me so we you know there's
this idea that the reason that we need
the right to free speech is because
let's say of the nobility of the human
spirit and there's an element that about
that that's true but there's a
important and more practical reason that
has more to do with the stupidity and
the ignorance of the human spirit and
and so I'm gonna kind of come at this
from two places I mean Carl Jung the
psycho analyst said that the fool was
the precursor to the savior from a
mythological perspective you can see an
echo of that an idea that comedians tell
the truth right and that the gesture in
the Kings Court is the only one because
he's beneath contempt he's the only one
that it can actually say what's true and
so that's the sort of thing that you
meant but it's also the case that the
reason the fool is the precursor to the
saviors because when you first start to
think you have to express yourself badly
and as if you're ignorant because you
don't know how to talk or think and you
are ignorant and so what that means is
that if you're not allowed to do to
think badly and and then you can't think
at all you can never learn to think at
all and so that's part of why the
restrictions on free speech are so
indefensible because everyone starts out
foolish and ignorant and so and the part
of the Enlightenment idea and and and I
would say even more deeply rooted ideas
before that that had been developing for
centuries is that people are at least
capable of in moving towards
enlightenment even though they're not
there and they never will be there it's
possible to stumble forward towards
enlightenment and and you can't also do
that just by thinking by yourself
because you're just not smart enough to
think by yourself and so free speech
isn't merely the right to criticize
those in power and it's often it's often
viewed that way and it's not also only
the right to say what you think it is
actually the right to think because even
what we're doing right now is thinking
you know so like I'm talking to you guys
and and and you might say well you're
not involved in the conversation but
that's not true because I'm watching you
to see if you if I'm on the right
wavelength you know if my words are
hitting their intended target and and
I'm trying to make sure that I I
construct my language so that the
communicative intent is
I want it to be and that's all process
of active thought and that's what
clarifies your spirit and improves your
behavior and and and in Nobles you
across time and so it isn't that free
speech is of value it's not that it's
it's a canonical value without that all
the other values that we hold dear that
that that people have fought so hard to
and so in such an unlikely manner to
preserve and produce that all disappears
and you end up with a populace that is
not only afraid to say what they what
they think but that doesn't even know
what they think because they haven't
been allowed to stumble around in the
dark like human beings have to do in
order to find some tiny fragment of
light so well as I sit here between two
Canadians you [ __ ] Canadians as
I sit here between two Canadians I
wonder you know the protections the
extra protections that we have in the
United States because of the First
Amendment the tradition based in
classical liberalism and true freedoms
and freedoms of speech you guys don't
have all of that in Canada and I think
it's partly what has gotten you into
somehow order of course do you see us
sort of whittling that away here I guess
the answer I guess I know your answer
but yes and I think it's okay moving on
yeah
Jordan s so a place like Canada in its
constitution has nominal protection for
free speech but it's subordinate to
other consider it can be trumped all the
time what's significant about the u.s.
is the First Amendment because the Bill
of Rights now there was the argument of
do we want to enumerate certain rights
because it implies that the other rights
are important but I think it was
crucially important that these rights
got enumerated because when a government
starts and when the culture starts
moving in a different direction what the
First Amendment it has become the
Constitution meant these are the powers
granted to government it can't do
anything else
and now the it's much more look that
government can do anything except what
is explicitly forbidden to it and the
First Amendment forbids
interference with religion it for its
freedom of speech freedom of the press
so that's why I think it's better in
other places than it here then in other
countries but the same forces that have
eroded it considerably in Europe and in
Canada or at work in the u.s. but it's
harder for them to get around the First
Amendment but what is I think the what's
prophesizing the direction we're going
to go in is that people don't understand
the meaning of the First Amendment they
break it up into little clauses even the
religion it's the free exercise and the
Establishment Clause and it's it should
be viewed as a package of what it's
trying to do is protect intellectual
freedom and it's specifying crucial
aspects of that about religion about
freedom of speech about freedom of the
press of assembly right to petition
government and this is what the founders
and I think particularly Jefferson and
Madison were trying to do is protect
intellectual freedom and that's the what
you have to understand that's what you
have to value and that if you really
understand it it has all kinds of
repercussions to put one controversial
one in I think if you really understand
intellectual freedom public universities
or a violation of it in the same way
establishing religion is that's really
problematic and against intellectual
freedom establishment in other areas
like in the university setting creates
all kinds of problems part of the battle
in the u.s. is just on this because I
think it's a resolvable but that's I
mean we can get into that kind of issue
everyone but yeah so it's there's unique
things about the US but I think it's
moving in a direction that everybody
else has moved how much of the problem
here is that we've allowed everything to
become political we talked about this a
little bit this afternoon that
everything now so politics obviously and
it's just on everyone's feed all day
long talking about Trump and whatever
else is going on but now it's seeping
into sports with the anthem and it's
seeping into Hollywood with everything
going on with Harvey Weinstein that
everything
has now become political and I think
that that is actually causing people on
one hand I view it as good because it's
making people think and reevaluate but
on the other hand this endless onslaught
of politics I don't think is and I don't
think it's precisely a political symptom
it's it's a symptom of deep discontent
at very fundamental levels of the
cognitive and perceptual structure that
unites us you know you can say if you
were a union you'd say there are there
are active forces at work in the
collective unconscious once again and
the collective unconscious I guess in
one way of looking at it is that it's
the set of assumptions that we share
that we don't know how to articulate you
know and and and we certainly have any
number of those because we're far more
complex than we can fully understand so
we know all sorts of things that we
don't know we know I mean one of the
things that people tell me quite
regularly is that they like watching
what I'm doing because I help them find
the words to describe things that they
already know you know and and that's
actually a hallmark of archetypal
thinking it's that we already do think
this way we think in a human way and at
particularly human way and we need to be
able to articulate that but this this
battle that's going on between let's say
the supremacy of group and individual
identity that that reaches its tendrils
up into everything and it's a symptom of
the depth of the problem in some sense
and so it is it's also part of the
spiral you know that that is undoing
things and pitting people against one
another but I see it as symptomatic it's
very difficult often when something is
happening to specify the correct level
of analysis right I mean some of you
know that I I got involved publicly in
in this sort of thing that we're
discussing now because I voiced my
opposition to a Canadian a piece of
Canadian legislation that purported to
do nothing but extend some of the
charter rights to people whose gender
identity didn't fit into the standard
binary categories which in some sense is
a it's
I'm not going to call it a trivial
matter because I don't think it is but
it's kind of a small country and it's
it's a side issue in many ways but that
isn't how it was treated like there was
something about that issue that was
emblematic of something far deeper and I
was trying to figure out exactly what
the right level of analysis was and I
think that part of the reason that
people have been paying attention to
what I've been saying is because I got
the level of analysis right and they
knew that something there was more going
on underneath the surface than met the
eye and everyone has that feeling I
would say at the moment and and it is
this are we going to allow ourselves to
be defined by our group membership and
if we are then well what are we going to
do with the people who aren't in our
groups just for starters and if we're
defined by our group membership like
which group because most of us can be
thrown into an enumerable set of groups
and and what does that mean for your
dignity as an individual or your value
to the state or to other individuals
like these are major problems and major
issues and I can't help but see behind
the postmodernist mask an absolute
hatred of especially successful
individuality and that it's it's it's
fundamentally motivated by something
like like a hellish resentment it's
something like that and that's the right
language to and it's it's insanely
dangerous and we better be careful
because the insane danger may manifest
itself and we're going to be very
unhappy if it does it has in many other
places and many other times and so it
would be good if we had enough sense to
remember what we're about and and and
pick up the proper the proper pieces
again and put everything back together
that would be very good yeah and what's
interesting it's not just dangerous in
the outward ways that we know it's all
dangerous when you know they're burning
down universities when when ben shapiro
who's a you know he's a conservative
thinker that that's really it this is
not this isn't even the level of Milo
this is
just an average conservative thinker
he's a quite good one but you know
people were saying well it was a success
Berkeley you know there was only one ATM
broken and only three windows are saying
and it cost them six hundred grand to
secure it to keep it safe but I'm
curious I'll kick it to you guys for a
second here how many of you have just
censored yourselves that there are times
when something comes up that you want to
post on Facebook or on Twitter or sign
us that you don't post just because you
don't want to deal with it yeah I mean
that that's pretty much everybody and
some of that might just be good sense
yeah
Touche
how many of you have secret Peppe
accounts Wow I got a hand back there
that's a rare moment of a frogman outing
himself all right there we go yeah you
must find it funny that the the pepe
thing is taken off people think you
sound like Kermit the Frog and Pepe has
become huge it's a real fraud thing
right now yeah I know I just that's one
of these things that I just can't figure
out at all like I made a video last year
where I wore a frog hat not partly
because people had been comparing me to
Kermit which I suppose as far as
satirical insults go is about as good as
they get so and I do actually sound a
lot like him which is actually rather
appalling so you know I wore this Frog
hat that this Indian Carver I knew
Native American Carver I knew and I know
very well had given me and he told me
that the Frog was a for them was a an
indicator of environmental degradation
and and of course the Frog is precisely
that because it lives in the water and E
and on land and it it it has very
sensitive skin and so if the frogs
disappear in the wetlands then that's
not a good sign and so I wore this hat
and talked about my role as spokes frog
and yeah yeah and I think I started with
that Kermit song about not being easy
being green something like that and then
I realized as soon as I posted it I
realized that this frog that my friend
had carved for me had red lips
and somebody tweeted that
that was the same frog as Pepe and I
thought oh my god I've just done myself
incorrectly and but they liked that the
string of coincidences that surrounded
that were so intense that that it I just
I still have no idea what to make of it
you know it's it's so many bizarre
things have happened well around me but
to me in the last year that I'm still
like recovering from it and probably
will be for about a decade ironically
that fraud day was the same day that
Alex Jones said that the government's
making frogs gay so something weird
going on the self-censorship now it's I
want you to I think it's a real
phenomenon but you need to distinguish
certain things you can be morally self
censoring yourself or you're just
intellectually afraid to speak out and
that the solution for that is just to
summon the courage to speak out so take
its we're not in any kind of unique
circumstance where it's hard to speak
out today for proper truth and proper
values but it was easy before go back in
American history the abolitionists they
were vilified for speaking out against
slavery but you have to distinguish is
it social and moral criticism people
won't want to associate with them then
you're gonna lose friends I know that's
happened to you is that's one level it's
another level if you're good and the
abolitionist I mean often we're worried
about this you're gonna be beaten up or
maybe even killed that is a wholly
different level and that is a level
where the government should be
protecting you so you asked earlier
about what's happening to free speech in
America there is no free speech in
regard to Islam I really think that so
when there's self-censorship in regard
to Islam it's because the government
won't protect the individuals who are
willing to speak and the I mean this
would happen with Rushdie it happened
with the Danish cartoon crisis if
newspapers don't reprint the cartoons
when it's so clearly news and if part of
what they say and part of what they said
is look we're scared of being attacked
of bombed the government is not going to
protect us that are not going on
to the instigators of this that's
self-censorship where government has
clear responsibility but there's other
kinds of what people who describe a
self-censorship where the solution is
not the government needs to protect your
rights it's you need to summon the moral
and intellectual courage to speak out on
these issues even if people are gonna go
after you what would you say to people
who would say well don't inflame people
oh don't drop in effect well I would say
first of all you know that you don't
want to make unnecessary enemies right
there's nothing wrong with prudence so
you want to choose your words carefully
but you know part of wisdom is knowing
what to be afraid of and many times many
many times in your life perhaps with
every important choice you make your
your you've got terror on one side and
terror on the other there's no way
forward that doesn't involve risk and
see there's a big problem with with
self-censorship
and that is that every time you fail to
express who and what you are in an
articulated manner you first of all lose
an opportunity to know yourself better
and that's that's not good because you
have to pilot yourself through life and
life is a very dangerous and treacherous
enterprise and if you don't know
yourself well then you won't pilot
yourself well and you will be hurt more
often than you need to be and that is
not trivial but the other thing is is
that you also weaken yourself and I'm
speaking as a clinical psychologist here
and I don't think there's any doubt
about this is that you know your your
mind is basically wired up in many many
different ways to determine what
constitutes a valid threat and that's
not an easy thing to figure out like if
you wake up in the morning and your side
is sore you know does that mean you
pulled a muscle or does it mean you have
cancer it's like you don't know you
can't tell it's very difficult to to to
determine exactly how threatening a
threat is and one of the ways that your
brain figures that out is to watch you
and it assumes that if you if you if you
move away from something if you if you
retreat from something it assumes that
the thing that you're retreating from is
bigger
than you and that you're smaller than it
and so it makes you just that much more
existentially weak and frightened and so
when you have something to say and you
don't say it then not only do you miss
an opportunity to articulate yourself
properly which is which is really
fundamentally necessary but you tell
yourself right down to the level of your
soul that there's less of you than there
could be and that makes the next retreat
even more likely and so you can easily
initiate a positive feedback loop where
you retreat and you get a little smaller
and your enemy gets a little bigger and
then you retreat again and you get a
little smaller and your enemy gets a
little bigger and then you're at a point
where even under each time you retreat
for success in life it's a recipe for
cowering in the corner and freezing and
so you know you might be afraid to say
what you have to say and you might have
every reason to be afraid but you should
even be more afraid of not saying what
you have to say because the consequences
of that as they accrue over the long
term are they'll undermine everything
for you they'll undermine your faith in
yourself they'll undermine your family
they'll undermine your society that is
not a place you want to go so yeah and
we can take that to a very personal
level for you guys I mean when when I do
these events at colleges one of the
questions that I always get asked and I
I'm guessing we're gonna probably get
asked it in a few minutes is well I have
a professor who disagrees with me or
he's into all of this postmodern stuff
and I don't want to speak my mind
because it's going to affect my grade
and I used to say when a couple years
ago when I was doing this I used to say
to them well probably you should just
suck it up get the grade and get out and
I actually completely disagree with that
now because if you guys now will silence
yourselves it doesn't suddenly magically
get easier when you're in the real world
and you have a job and a spouse and kids
and all these other worries so in a
weird way it kind of sucks for you now
and you want to get out and you want to
get a good grade so you can get the good
job and you can have all the things that
you want in your life
but I think you're totally right that it
will never get easier it will just be a
constant whittling
way at your ability to ever do it do you
think it's not easy now it ain't gonna
get one every time this is something
else you need to know and there's a very
solid literature on this is that you
know one of the most ancient one of the
most ancient ideas that human beings
have had is that in some manner our
spirits speak being into existence you
know and it's like the hallmark of
consciousness it's one of the reasons
that individuals are valuable and and
it's a very deep idea and and and a very
necessary idea and I believe one that's
fundamentally true but it carries with
it certain more mortal perils you might
say if you falsify your speech in the
service of a proximal goal you corrupt
your soul and or I could say more
technically that you damaged your psyche
those are very similar ideas but the the
evidence for that is crystal clear you
know because what happens to people who
say things they don't believe is they
come to believe the things they say and
the reason for that is we talked a
little earlier about the fact that a lot
of you is unarticulated right and and so
there are things you know but you don't
know that you know them and you don't
know how to talk about them and so then
what you do is you decide that to reach
a proximal goal like getting a good
grade well you have to say what the
professor wants so you write out an
essay you know there's no soul in it and
you feel sick while you're writing it
and you're not interested in it and you
feel small which are always always hints
from your being that you shouldn't be
doing that but you do it anyways and
then at the end you've got two choices
like you're either a liar and a coward
or you believe what you wrote and
there's plenty of psychological evidence
for this is what people do is decide
that they believe what they wrote
because it's less painful than noting
that you're a liar and a coward and not
only that you've articulated a
counter-argument and so your original
conviction remains unarticulated and the
counter-argument is articulated so
you've built yourself your own enemy and
you will pay for that you pay for that
with Adam
of your character and your character is
what sustains you through life there
isn't you don't have in any in any
fundamental sense you don't have
anything else because that's the thing
that enables you to master the continual
onslaught of chaos and uncertainty that
will that you will be faced with for
your entire life you do not pollute your
character you pay for it and so does
everyone else
and if it goes far enough then everyone
else pays horribly for it that's the
lesson of the 20th century so don't do
that and if you do that University it's
like a it's like a mortal sin it's it
runs absolutely contrary to the spirit
of the institution it is precisely the
opposite - it's the absolute polar
opposite to why you're here do not do it
and it's also a kind of it's a kind of
second-rate cynicism because even though
there is a fair bit of rot in the
academic institutions most of the time
if you write an articulate essay that
the professor doesn't agree with you
will not be punished with a failing
grade it's very rare that that actually
happens now there is the odd professor
who's so damn corrupt that that's going
to be the case but I've talked to lots
of students and counseled them to write
down what they think and they're gray
generally surprises them quite
spectacularly because they're invested
in the damn essay and so they do the
work right and they put a little passion
into it and and they're not bored by it
or made sick by what they're producing
and then they end up with a grade that's
far better than they think so you know
often it's a well I'm going to take the
easy route out but I'm going to justify
it by relating it to my career progress
it's like really guys that's pretty
pathetic you know seriously it's it's
pathetic and and I don't mean to be
morally judgemental I mean that it's
pathetic
in that what it will do is make you weak
and Craven and probably you don't want
that you know like why would you want
that when you could be strong and
forthright instead like that's a way
better choice so don't don't say things
that you don't believe
especially don't write things that you
don't agree with you you it's a bad idea
it's it's a terrible idea so don't do
that ever ever it goes back to the issue
that you were bringing up which I
definitely agree with that speech and
thought go together and the
totalitarians knew this this is why in
Soviet Russia they would parade
everybody into meetings where you had to
espouse the dogma most people didn't
believe it but the total and Terrans
knew that it does something internally
to the person to make them speak things
they don't agree with over and over and
over it's very very corrupting and to do
that to yourself when you're not being
forced to do it it's crazy
so everything that you're talking about
really is about the individual I mean we
we've sort of hovered around this that
this really comes down to the individual
the capacity of you to control your own
mind understand your own thoughts how do
you think versus the collective I know
you're you're big on this concept and
what's the best advice you could give to
college students about why how to avoid
collectivism because it's it's thriving
on college campuses which is why we're
in this position in the first place
I mean I think one of the things that
there's a lot to say here one of the
things is to recognize how often you're
being pushed in a collectivist direction
and it's not always obvious but I think
part of what makes collectivism
collectivism is a determinism so the
reason you're a member of a collective
of a group and that that's integral to
your identity is because it's all the
same forces shaping every member of the
group but that means there's no
individuals in it you're all shaped by
factors outside of you antecedent to you
whether it's viewed as your race your
gender your culture I mean
multiculturalism was one of the main
doctrines the postmodernist push and the
whole perspective was you're a product
of your ethnicity and ethnicity was a
blend of your race of your culture which
is ideas and traditions and so
all that this is what someone's a
product of this is how you have to look
at yourself how you look should look at
other people and what is never there
never mentioned because they're all
determinist is yeah but what about the
choices I make the control I have over
my own mind and my own life what about
the whole issue of it's a self-made
character Aristotle called it you have a
nature and then you have a second nature
and the second nature is the nature you
create as a result of your choices what
about that and you never taught that
because most people today for various
reasons or determinants and it's to
recognize I'm in that environment and if
I reject that then I have to pay
attention to things about myself that
nobody is telling me to pay attention to
and that is that's the root of
individuality if there is an individual
it's the choices of thinking you engage
in you initiate you pursue you sustain
and you're capable of doing that even if
everybody's telling you knowing you're
just a product of all outside forces and
what's particularly interesting about
this of course is that if you were to
judge everyone by their skin color or by
their sexuality or by their religion or
whatever else that actually is
prejudiced I mean these are these are
often the people who are claiming that
everyone is a bigot and a homophobe and
a racist and now a white supremacist and
there's that but if you look at someone
and you think well because you're a
woman you have to think this way or
because you're black you have to think
this way or you're white so you have to
think this way that is prejudging that
is actually what the essence of
prejudice is even even to define
diversity in the way that it's being
defined is it's not only technically
incorrect I do believe that it's racist
and misogynist or sexist not misogynist
and the reason for that is that like
there are different you can break people
up into groups in various ways and so in
one of the consequences of breaking them
up in some ways is that you break them
up in ways so that there's a difference
between group a and Group B there's an
actual difference maybe it's a
difference in wealth or who knows like
because it depends on how you break them
up but the scientific evidence on this
is clear as well even if you take the
relatively large differences that exist
between some groups so here's an example
there's actually quite a large
difference between men and women in
terms of what their intrinsic interests
are this is something James d'amour
tried to point out and was pilloried for
it but the the evidence is very strong
that on average women are more
interested in people and on average men
are more interested in things but and
that's a fairly large difference as far
as those sorts of differences go but
there's still more overlap between men
and women than there are differences and
so the idea that you get diversity by
selecting across group identity is
technically wrong because there's more
diversity within any group than there is
between any two groups it's wrong it's
wrong and then but it's worse than that
it's morally wrong because you're making
the assumption that they don't racist
assumption that the group defines the
content of the spirit it's like there
isn't a more racist claim than that
there's no a daughter more sexist claim
than that that I know what you're like
because I know something about your
external features it's like how the hell
did we ever get to the place where we
thought that had something to do with
diversity it's it's it's anti diversity
in the most profound way it's absolutely
insulting to a person who regards
himself or herself as an individual to
be judged in that manner and to be
constantly her aimed for bigotry for
opposing the evil Trinity of equity
diversity and inclusivity is it's it's a
it's a kind of in it's a miracle of
inversion that that can even be the case
and I would say we need to know how to
identify the radical leftists let's say
and separate them from the Liberals and
liberals are very bad at that they're
very bad at doing that
I'm trying yeah
so I would say here those three words if
you hear people mouth those words equity
diversity inclusivity you know you know
who you're dealing with and you should
step away from that because it's a it's
not acceptable it's Matt it's a mask of
virtue that's it and underneath it is
something that's truly awful and so and
it's incumbent on liberal types to start
to draw a line between their classic
liberal beliefs and these terrible
postmodern neo-marxist ideas that that
have like that have a pedigree of
genocide behind them so well you know
what I think we want to get to the QA
because we were all saying before how
that often is the most enjoyable part of
this whole thing so how about give these
guys are out of applause
so we've got two mics right here right
up in the front so if you guys want to
just come on down and you can even say
mean things to us and we will not have
you escorted out and all we ask is that
you kind of kind of keep it a little bit
brief because obviously we want to get
to as many of you guys as possible hello
my name is helen dr. peterson i just
have to say thank you for everything
that you've done i've been following
your work for about a year and i showed
it to my father and feel in many ways as
though you have helped me sort of save
my dad from the belly of the whale
yeah he's he at sixty years old as in
the best physical and spiritual shape of
his life since reading maps of meanings
so I'm just I feel indebted hey my
pleasure man that's a great
and this question can be for both of you
is there something about the archetypes
that drive the collective psyche of the
West that is University universally
non-transferable how do you mean
universally non-transferable
um unique I guess you could say I would
say the articulation of it is unique but
not the archetypes like the archetypes
this is sort of pertinent to something
dave said earlier about and and encore
as well about the causal forces at work
you know in an in a materialistic world
there's culture and nature but in the
archetypal world there's three elements
there's culture that's generally
symbolized with masculine symbolism and
there's nature generally feminine but
there's a third factor and that's often
symbolized as the Sun and that's the
factor that's associated with conscious
choice and free will and we don't know
what to do with that in our scientific
materialistic models but that Trinity
let's say that of masculine feminine and
the third factor as far as I can tell
that's universal now it's articulated to
a different degree in different cultures
and I think that one of the things that
makes the West unique is that that third
factor has been articulated most
completely in the West the other one of
the other things I think that's being
articulated in the West perhaps more so
than in other places is the distinction
between good and evil so and I think
that that those are two major
philosophical advantages and they're
actually part of what grounds our
political system so the archetypes
they're the same but the expression and
philosophical articulation is I would
say relatively unique in the West how do
you what do you think the West was able
to do that in such a unique way
divine providence I can't I can't say I
don't know I mean the thing is if you
think about this from a biological
perspective you know that many Western
ideas have spread everywhere very
rapidly you know and it just may be that
the it the West happened to get there
first
with regards to the historical timeframe
we're only talking you know a few dozen
centuries something like that and from
from a biological perspective that's
nothing right it's it's like we got we
got there two minutes before the next
people got there that's all I don't know
other than I can't say other than that
okay thank you so much hi first of all
thank you all for being here
I've Dave I respect the work that you do
with the Rubin report so much although
you gotta get out of it I'm sorry
[Music]
yeah they usually love the beard bearded
guys said keep the beard Brandon beard
the professor said keep the beard all
right maybe it's just me it has to the
beard has a twitter account there's
nothing I can really trending it's all
right
yeah which I guess for all of you which
do you think is more dangerous for free
speech is it the censoring of yourselves
use that you mentioned this a bit
is it the censoring of yourselves or is
it censorship from the group around you
from the government say you're your own
peers which you think is more dangerous
for free speech at the moment I believe
it's self censorship I look there's a
lot of things wrong with our government
at the moment there's a lot of reasons
that I talk about limited government all
the time and I want to get the power of
your life back to you and we should have
states rights and not everything should
be done by the federal government I'm
not even going to go into Trump or any
of that but that is secondary to what I
see happening because I do this every
day
now and I and I talked to people like
you and I see constantly people are
afraid to say what they think in the
freest country in the history of the
world the incredible American experiment
that has brought more people here from
every corner of Earth and all it is is
an experiment and it's worked pretty
damn well for a couple hundred years and
yes are there problems do we have real
issues of course there's nothing perfect
you know I think a lot of people on the
Left right now they want to manage
everything they think they can perfect
the system and then it'll suddenly be
magically wonderful for everyone at all
times except we're the problem with the
system we're not perfect that's that's
part of being human so for me and for
the conversations that I have every week
and when I go out and I meet people I
mean the fact that every single one of
you basically raised your hand when I
asked you self-censor and I'm guessing
not none of the things that you were
gonna post on Facebook we're gonna be
truly evil or racist or any of that
stuff but you're silencing yourselves
and then I think Jordans answer on why
that is corrosive to you as a human
being I think that's much more dangerous
but I'm happy to hear from you guys if
agree with that it's self-censorship and
it's I think over the long term you get
the government you've earned so if we're
as citizens are unwilling to speak up
and defend freedom of speech in on
particular issues where we're self
censoring and on the whole value of
freedom of speech you can't blame the
government that
well it doesn't uphold it because it
doesn't think it we want it it would be
a very different situation if 90% of
Americans were demanding freedom of
speech and the government was doing
nothing about it then you might say well
the poky the problem is we need to
change them but that's not what is
happening right now so I definitely
think it's the former when you have a
you might say there's an external tyrant
that's trying to make you into a slave
and there's an internal tyrant that's
trying to make you into a slave and
every time you allow the internal tyrant
to to win you make it stronger and again
I mean that technically because your
your mind is is composed in some sense
of competing systems and which of those
systems domine
depends on which system gets rewarded
and so if the tyrant says silence and
you agree then that system wins and gets
a little bit stronger and the part that
got defeated gets a little bit weaker
and so you don't want to do that to
yourself it's a really unless you want
to be a slave that's beholden to a
tyrant and and and to have that
constitute your inner life you don't
want that and well unless that's what
you want I would say think that through
very carefully because you don't want to
be a slave to your own tyrant that's
that's hell and it's a bad place to go
to so thank you dr. Peterson
so you've suggested that the proper
university trains one to become
articulate and if I understand it right
a and a corrupted University would
compel you to make arguments that you
didn't really believe in and you'd fail
to become articulate if you were suppose
the victim of a corrupted University
where should one defer to or go to to
learn to become articulate well I think
the I really think the best way that you
can learn to be articulated is to write
you know and when I talk to students I
actually have a guide little guide to
writing on my on my webpage and one of
the things it says I mean writing an
essay is actually a spiritual journey
and and I mean that most seriously you
know if you're bored writing an essay
it's because you're writing it wrong at
minimum you should be terrified
hopefully you should be at least
interested because if you haven't picked
a topic that that grips you about which
you have something to say a need to say
then you've picked the wrong topic and
the act of writing is its it is it is
the act of bringing something new into
being and you want to bring the right
thing into being you don't want to bring
a monster a miss shape and monster into
being and believe me I've read lots of
undergraduate essays that were miss
shapen monsters that's
sure so so if you want to be articulate
you do some writing because that's
that's hard thinking and then you read
read geniuses like you can actually read
geniuses for free which is quite
remarkable right you go on Amazon and
anything that's more than 50 years old
you can download on your Kindle for like
one cent and so if you're being if
you're not being educated by your
professors and that's actually very
common you can educate yourself that's
what a library is for and in fact if you
go to university really what a
university is is a place where a society
rewards you with an identity so that you
could become educated if you had a mind
to and and a lot of it is something you
have to do yourself no but you can find
out who to read they're great writers
they're they're not great because
they're part of an oppressive
patriarchal structure they're great
because they tell you things that if you
don't know you are going to be in very
much trouble you know so and there's
just an unlimited number of resources
like that so you know go to your classes
get your grades get your accreditation
don't sacrifice your soul to do it and
at the same time read what you should
read read read those people that have
been universally regarded as great
because they're regarded in that manner
because they're actually great so well
I'm writing my first book right now and
I think I just decided I'm not letting
you look at the first draft that is the
key okay so this is kind of aimed at all
of you but mainly dr. Peterson why is it
do you think that uh here we go that
Marxism is such a rooted ideology
compared to things like classical
liberalism or all of these other
ideologies that we see like this thing's
been around since the mid 1800s and it's
taken over almost everything especially
college campuses why do you think that
is well that's a good question I mean I
think the the first communists let's say
the Russians
say for the sake of argument they were
much less reprehensible philosophically
than today's Marxists and the reason for
that was well they had a utopian vision
and not that that's necessarily a good
thing but they didn't necessarily know
that it was a bad thing right and so and
the old aristocracy or peon structure
was crumbling and there'd been a
terrible war and you know the Czarist
regime was well compared to the
communist regime it was heaven on earth
but you know it had its problems and so
there in it even as Nietzsche said you
know that that communism would be worth
it as an experiment but he also said and
this was in will to power that hundreds
of millions of people would die as a
consequence which is one of the most
remarkable prophecies I think that have
ever been uttered by anyone ever okay so
it's attractive it's utopian but then
there's the dark side of it right which
means everyone who has more than you got
it by stealing it from you and that it
really appeals to the cane like element
of the human spirit right everyone who
has more than me got it in a manner that
was corrupt and that justifies not only
my Envy but my actions too to level the
field and so to speak you know and and
to look virtuous well doing it and so
there's there's a tremendous philosophy
of resentment that I think is driven now
also by a very pathological anti human
ethos that you also see at the base of
of much of the environmentalist movement
it's not like we're not doing some
stupid things to the planet like what
we're doing to the oceans for example is
reprehensible beyond comprehension but
you know I've heard environmentalists
state quite straightforwardly that human
beings are a cancer on the planet it's
like if someone says that to you you
know you should move away from that
person very very quickly because that
statement is genocide 'el in its in its
spiritual or racial origin and so I
think there's a there's our
there's a whole cluster of unexamined
motives of resentment that primarily
drive the the resurgence of the Marxism
but it's also a consequence of the poor
the biased education that that that that
our children receive you know they know
a bit about the Second World War and
about the Nazis but they don't know
anything about what happened in the
Soviet Union in China like often in
universities and I teach a personality
course it's like that's not where you
should be learning about the six million
Ukrainians who died of starvation in the
1930s but most of my students have never
heard of any of that it's like what the
hell we fought a whole Cold War about
that we damn near annihilated the planet
because of it and all of a sudden it's
well it's an inconvenient for the
neo-marxists to notice that that the
regime's of of Stalin and Mao were
brutal beyond comprehension so how about
if we don't talk about it you know so
there's lots of corruption that's
driving this but a huge part of it is
resentment and like I think the worst
emotions are resentment the worst
actions are resentment deceit and
arrogance and you get those three
working together boy you've got a force
that you better be careful with do you
think it's dying off well anyway
do you think Marxism is dying off or
going away at all or do you think it's
getting stronger I think that what's
happened is that it's it's trans mutated
into this post-modernism and identity
politics which was really really devious
really devious and that was a
consequence of the French intellectuals
mostly Derrida and Foucault but but it's
not going away what's happened instead
is that it's taken a new strategic tak
and it's one that no one really
envisioned what it's doing is taking
over the administration of mid-level
bureaucracies everywhere so it's not so
much a threat at the highest level of
political organization but that isn't
necessarily where much of the the power
over individuals resides it resides in
these smaller political structures some
political structures like like school
for example or or in Canada right now
our law society in Ontario has made it
mandatory for lawyers to produce a
statement of principles that they
provide a template for they tell you
what your damn statement of principles
should be and they're basically equity
diversity and inclusivity statements and
if you don't write out your statement of
principles declaiming your agreement
with these principles and simultaneously
essentially admitting that you're a
racist then you don't get your license
so we're fighting a big war about that
right now in Ontario we might even win
it looks like we might win you never
know but but it's also partly because
ordinary people are too complacent about
the mid-level bureaucrats who rule over
them you know we're willing to allow
those relatively small positions of
power to be taken over by groups that
are very good at doing that sort of
thing and we need to wake up to that
because it's seriously not good and it's
very difficult to fight back against so
thank you all right we got we got a ton
so let's just keep let's keep rolling
here all right I'll keep the beard I can
see I can see it thank you yeah 20 years
ago if you grew up in a small southern
town and you're interested in a not
popular idea such as Marxism or Buddhism
or whatever what you could do is go to
your local library read the two books by
Karl Marx there and then talk to your
uncle and mechanic or your high school
civics teacher about those ideas and you
either think huh I've got something here
let me go to university and work on it
or maybe I was wrong about this and get
back to you know the standard path most
people take you know and we now we have
the rise of the Information Age which on
the one hand you can get every great
work of literature it's 50 years or
older for one cent but on the other hand
you love all these echo chambers dark
holes on Reddit and 4chan where if you
don't espouse everything that one
particular group says then you're
immediately banned and have no voice
because of this we have so many people
that when you go home for Thanksgiving
you don't want to talk about the
election with your uncle because you
know it's it's a life or death thing and
on this group you know that you know I
need to hit up with a bike lock instead
of talking with them about what's
I think we need to come back to the
point where we talked to our uncle in
our high school civics teacher about
these things and pull ourselves a little
bit away and because you guys I know
talk about these things what are some
actionable baby steps that we can take
as students and citizens as people in
the workforce to make it okay to talk
about politics and religion and how much
we make and all these things that matter
well I would say five words Twitter is
not real life
that that really yeah this is real life
this right here is real life you are
real people in front of us we're real
people in front of you you know I'm sure
some of you guys know I took all of
August off and I did not look at a
screen I locked my phone and it's safe
and I was working on my book and I was
just living like a regular person used
to ten years ago and I found that I was
more patient even when I was online at
the supermarket that I was looking at
the cashier instead of just quit you
know whatever the hell I was doing I was
gonna say snapchatting I don't even have
it anymore but get that stuff is not
real there is value to it it helped
create revolutions Tahrir Square in
Egypt had a lot to do with the online
world I mean there's incredible value to
it but it's becoming crazy twitter
particularly is becoming insane so you
can spend a lot of time on Reddit and
4chan fighting with anonymous people I
mean most of these people are anime
foxes pink foxes if a guy in a pink fox
hat was running across the street and
told you to go [ __ ] yourself I'm pretty
sure you wouldn't engage what did you
just say to me we're gonna sit down and
work this thing out no but but for some
reason
smart people people smarter than me are
sitting online arguing with anonymous
crazy people and by the way I think
there's some value in anonymity online I
think there's reasons that it can be
good as I just said the the Egypt thing
but that stuff is not all real you know
what's real sitting down with your uncle
and and the other things that you
mentioned and do the best you can at it
and I say that as someone that can stare
at my phone half the day so we all got
to get better at it but I think that's
the best answer on that one yeah I mean
we talked a bit a little bit about this
I'm not on social media want for that
reason that and I think
part of what one needs to learn is that
communication is a two-way process and
that thinking takes time you have to
really think what you're saying I mean
you were talking about writing an essay
the idea to me that but people are
online and in 15 seconds they have a 200
character retort to something as though
they've thought about what the other
person is sent
he thinks Twitter's 200 characters this
is truly not 40 40 it's that's not what
thinking looks like and if you're not
willing to listen to the other person
even when you disagree with them and
even when you think they're crazy and
you're not trying to get at but is there
anything animating them are there is
there anything that they're concerned
about in any problem that they're trying
to solve for instance I'm very anti
Trump but I will listen to the people
who are Pro Trump or vote if I'm trying
to get it what what exactly is it that
you're interested in here what what is
driving you but that takes time and
effort and if you're not willing to put
that in you're not actually interested
in thinking or in communicating so I
think that comment you make about
listening is really the key you know one
good way to engage in political
discussion is to find someone that you
don't agree with which obviously isn't
that difficult and ask them like why do
you believe that you know and not like
why do you believe that you know that's
not a question because they actually
have a reason for believing what they
believe and you know if people love to
have to be questioned in a genuine way
because they love to be listened to
people insanely love to be listened to
because they need to express themselves
and think and questioning is a wonderful
way to engage in a political
conversation because I mean imagine you
came up to a penguin and you could ask
it what it was like and it could tell
you you think wow that'd be pretty
interesting I can find out about penguin
so you can find someone with some
strange set of beliefs and you could ask
them why they believe it and they'll
actually tell you and most of the time
that's insanely fascinating you know you
it's it's it is very much like
interrogating some kind of bizarre form
of animal life and northie
you're not an equally bizarre form of
animal life but but and and then often
the other thing that's so interesting is
that if you really listen to people it's
very very likely that they will tell you
something you didn't know even if they
tell you 50 things you think are
ridiculous
if you really engage them in
conversation you'll come away with
something that you didn't know and
that's a treasure man because hey now
sudden you know something that you
didn't know what a good deal and so
questioning honest not arrogant it's
like okay you don't agree with me but
that doesn't mean that you're the devil
incarnate probably so so everyone has
something to teach you and sometimes
that's an example of what not to say but
I guess the thing is like you said
before instead of these negative
feedback loops we have to set up a
positive feedback loop so you start by
talking to the penguin guy because he's
easy and non-threatening then after that
you go the next level up and sooner or
later if you keep doing that then you'll
be strong enough like the guy with a
fear of elevators to go out and talk to
the guy mr. Ian Wright I realize that I
probably opened the gates of Hell when I
mock the two it was at the pink foxes
did I say Fox is it a fox so let me just
look in the camera I'm sorry you people
are wonderful please leave me alone okay
hi so I have two questions that are
connected the first one
dr. Gotti you said that there's a
difference between morally self
censoring and that's a direct quote
versus intellectually speaking out or or
the government censoring someone's
thought so why does there have to be a
difference as my question and I guess
this is addressed to both you and dr.
Peterson and can you clarify that
difference more concretely because to me
it seemed like that was approaching kind
of tiptoeing around a concession to free
speech or a concession to censoring free
speech in that this if this line is not
clearly defined you could very easily or
you could say I suppose that something
is an example of moral censorship as
opposed to the other kind of
intellectual censorship and then
relatedly a common reason
for censorship I think that we see on
college campuses is this idea of well
there are people who have more privilege
that people who have less privilege and
if you if a person in a higher state of
privilege says something to a person
with lower privilege due to that
privilege that the person in the higher
position has it can be seen as offensive
because they don't understand those
experiences of the of the person with
lower privilege and say if you know we
classically here the example of the
white sis had male heterosexual male I'm
talking down to you know say the black
trans woman whatever whichever you know
kinds of oppression you'd like to
identify that that can be seen is
problematic because that that this
person with more privilege does not have
the same experience does not have the
same understanding of what it's like to
be this person and hence that's an
example of why free speech can be
censored for that person so I guess to
restate one could you clarify the
difference between those two ideas and
to where is their relationship just real
quick before you guys that just so you
guys know we weren't gonna do this but I
think maybe we will just cuz I feel good
about you guys we're gonna sacrifice a
white heterosexual man at the end of
this right here on this table
I'm ready me any of you alright you
you're in you raise your hand purse okay
I was putting intellectual and moral
self censorship together so you can be
you can be scared because you're gonna
be morally attacked your bat you're a
bad person for voicing or holding those
views or you can just be intellectually
attack you're a stupid person for
holding those views that is if that's
all the opposition is then what you
should be doing is holding fast if you
what you truly think and what you truly
believe in what you truly value you
should be speaking out and for that I
was contrasting that to when because the
term self censorship is used in that
context and it's used in the context
where a person's right to speak is
actually no longer protected by the
government and I think in regard to
Islam that is the case that people
rightly fear for their lives to speak
out on this issue and that means
physically killed I mean I've done
events with Fleming Rose was the editor
of the Danish cartoons and I've worn a
bulletproof vest that's you do it that's
a very different context that someone's
gonna tell me I'm stupid or someone who
can to tell me I'm a bad person and I
get that criticism that I'm stupid in a
bad person all the time I'm I work at
the Iran Institute there's many people
who love wine Ren there's many people
who hate Iran and think she's the
stupidest person in the 20th century
she's evil she advocates selfishness
that everyone knows is evil I get that
kind of opposition and if I cowered to
that opposition it would shrink my soul
if I cower and I'm afraid to speak about
Islam and we decide we're not gonna do
an event because someone would blow us
up that's a very different form and that
one is the government's responsibility
to say no we will protect you we will do
whatever we can to protect Rushdie
protected Danish cartoonist to protect
the Garlin event in Texas where they're
drawing the Prophet Mohammed the that's
the responsibility of a cover so that
those were the two categories I was
distinguishing on the issue of privilege
is calm I don't think it's a valid
concept it's used to intimidate morally
there is an issue there that a part of
what came up in the other question that
you want to really try to communicate
with another person you should be
sensitive to the issue that someone can
have very different experiences than you
very different circumstances grown up in
a different culture and a different kind
of family that makes differences for how
they think about things what they've
been exposed to or not and that in terms
of communicating you should be sensitive
to the issue it's not an issue of power
or a privilege it's just an issue of
different context and that is relevant
to communication and you really should
be thinking and you can unknowingly
insult people and so but that that's not
an issue of not what don't talk to
people as a result
it's rather talk in a constructive
genuine way with people and it's part of
what should be interesting about a
university you meet all kinds of people
with all kinds of different views
backgrounds that you can learn from but
the whole postmodern view is you it's
kind of collective subjectivism that
this person grew up in this group this
person grew up in this group and they
can't communicate because they live in
different realities that
is totally wrong you live in one reality
you can't different experiences in it
and what you're trying to do is learn
from each other all right there's a ton
of you so let's we'll try to keep it a
little briefer just in hey guys dr.
Peterson huge fan Dave as well keep the
beard and dr. Gaddy thank you for coming
to one of the biggest threats against
free speech is the hecklers veto we've
seen this with Milo at Berkeley and Ann
Coulter as well and charles Murray at
Middlebury I want to ask why do you guys
think the mainstream media is reluctant
to often reluctant to shine a light or
condemn the use of the hecklers veto by
groups like Ann Tifa I mean it's pretty
simple actually they don't want to be
called racist they don't want these
tactics that have effectively silenced
so many of you guys who are not racist
in the first place they don't want it to
be turned on them so they've created an
intellectual hostage situation and I
would say the simplest answer if you
want to stop these people you know what
you do I've done events I did UCLA with
Milo and a bunch of kids created a human
wall so they're not against walls they
just don't like Trump's wall but you
know what you know what you know what
you want to silence him don't show up
you will disappear like Baltimore it
will it will just go but instead the
more you burn these things down you
silence these people he and and whoever
else and I'm not even making this
personally about Milo but any of these
people will be stronger after are they
more known or less known after always
more so let them speak and and usually
if they're bad ideas they'll crumble on
their own
thank you hi my question is on media
responsibility so we talked a lot about
that in many of my classes and we look
at how media distorts reality and into
complete fabrication fabrications at
some points and I'm even like conducting
a psychology experiment on what you
would call fake news but with the First
Amendment we have freedom of press and
freedom of speech but with Trump's
recent tweets it's been called into
question media regulation so I was
wondering how you feel about that how
where do you draw the line between
freedom of press
and the press complete outright lies
sometimes well for me on this one I mean
look you can say whatever you want it
doesn't mean that there aren't
repercussions so if the media is
blatantly saying false things well we
actually do have libel laws we do have
slander laws I'm for those laws you know
something like Gawker that was violating
Hulk Hogan's right to privacy well guess
what happened they got destroyed I have
no problem with that you have a right to
privacy you have a right to free speech
you don't have a right to not have
repercussions happen when you speak as
for Trump look you know he look his
Twitter it's obviously ridiculous and he
can the thing is he has the same right
to free speech as the rest of us do now
if he was trying to pass laws to stop it
to stop pres from doing some of these
things and he actually did tweet
something the other day about taking
NBC's license away now I'm obviously not
for that but he didn't try to pass a law
about it yet and thankfully we still do
have three branches of government they
don't really work the way they're
supposed to but in a lot of ways Trump
hasn't been able to get a lot of the
things that he's wanted done because the
system actually is working at the moment
so you you have free speech and and you
know Trump has it too and so does NBC
and I'd love to read your paper because
I think it's I think it's the topic
actually related to this whole I think
part of what's happened to the press too
is a consequence of the postmodernist
insistence on identity politics and the
relativism of truth because within that
universe the the world is sort of
portrayed as a battleground between
identity groups each of which are only
motivated by power and if you buy into
that then you can abandon any commitment
to the truth because there is no truth
and that that removes the moral
responsibility of journalists to do
anything but utter their opinion you
know they're they're they're they're
temperamental political opinion and so
it's convenient I mean and it's
certainly the case I would say that in
my lifetime I've seen a substantial
decline in the quality of print
journalism and in television news like
quite pronounced that I think that's
partly why
YouTube has become such a phenomena
among young people there they're
actually rather sick of that who would
like to get some information but I think
it's part of this underlying war that we
talked about earlier and and the press
are increasingly seem to increasingly
regard themselves as opinion shapers or
something content providers and opinion
shapers you know God - horrible phrases
instead of people who are trying to get
a get a handle on what's going on and
communicate it to the rest of the world
which really is what journalists were
doing I would say before the 1980s I
mean they that is really what they did
at least for a while so thank you my
question was on a similar note the value
of free speech seems to have fallen out
of favor with these postmodernist simply
because for lack of a better term it's
just too confusing for them that it
provides more confusion than solutions
and their proposition is to to burn away
what has been before simply for the sake
of doing something new because in their
estimation of things it's not working at
present now whether they convict that
through power gains or language gains or
deleting the right people off Facebook
it seems to be that that elimination is
is what they're trying to do with speech
and in some of your previous lectures on
free speech you've talked about the
differentiation between speech proper
and then truth speech speech that
actually contains something to move
forward with so my question is can a
method of discernment for what is true
be externalized from the individual is
there really a reliable method of
verification for what is true outside of
somebody's own subjective experience
well I think I think science is one
method of reliable verification and it
clearly works I mean here we are the
electricity is on and everything you
know it's itself itself evidently true
in some sense but I do believe that and
this probably goes along with the
arguments we were talking about earlier
with regards to that third element of
human character I do
that you have the power to discern truth
like you have to learn to develop it but
if you didn't have that like how could
you live you wouldn't be able to
distinguish between the kind of enacted
falsehood that would kill you and the
sort of thing that would facilitate your
movement through time and space like you
you are a rational creature and it's
deeper than that because because you're
a creature I think who partakes in the
process of creation but you certainly
have the capacity to distinguish truth
from falsehood it needs to be developed
and you could be fooled and you can make
mistakes and all of that but you
wouldn't be able to live in a world of
regularities if you didn't have that
capacity so well if I may add something
I know we're in a rush but I think I
think it comes to the line of the
intoxication of group psychology versus
having individual conviction I mean how
is an individual especially one that's
already swayed by say you know jargon
about the proletariat how are they
supposed to have a moment where they can
realize the difference between having a
truthful conviction versus having a
conviction delivered for them and spoken
for you well alright so Solzhenitsyn
talked about this a fair bit and the
Gulag Archipelago you know when he was
trying to retool his character because
he realized in himself he realized that
he himself was one of the tyrannical
forces that produced the conditions that
that landed him in in the work counts so
he's willing to take personal
responsibility for it and he said that
the first thing he did was sort of go
over his life memories with a fine-tooth
comb and try to identify times where he
had done something that he knew to be
wrong now sometimes you might do
something and you don't know whether
it's right or wrong you know so let's
say you're ignorant and you might be
making a mistake but you don't know but
and I think this is a universal human
experience people know when people know
sometimes that what they're saying isn't
true and people know sometimes that what
they're doing is wrong and they state
the untruth and they do what's wrong
anyways and one thing you can do is stop
doing that and that is Lee the same as
telling the truth exactly
it's it's it's ceasing to utter and
enact falsehoods and you can you can
define the things that's what's
interesting about that it isn't it isn't
it says it's a game you play with
yourself it's like well for some reason
I know that what I'm about to do is
wrong stop doing that and you you clean
up your vision right that's a matter of
taking the beam mode if you're raw you
clean up your vision and as you do that
progressively and Solzhenitsyn's is an
excellent example of this your capacity
to discern truth from falsehood grows
and that means that your capacity to
operate effectively in the world grows
because there's no real difference
between those things so I would say the
place you start this is why you know
it's become an internet meme I talk to
help people to clean up their rooms to
put themselves in order if you're in
disorder and you know that there are
things you could do that we're even
small that would improve that to some
degree do them and then keep doing them
and that that works across time it's
it's also humble you know in the sense
of proper humility start where you are
fix the things that you can fix quit
saying things you know that make you
weak and that are lies and if you do
that for a reasonable period of time it
will transform you completely so and
anyone can do that I believe that anyone
can do that you can start wherever you
happen to be so thank you hi thank you
all for coming here so my question is
maybe primarily addressed to dr.
Peterson but really to all of you so I
completely agree with what you said
about diversity in the in the sense that
I mean the way people seem to think of
it now it's at best
annoying and and at worst it's actively
destructive right but the thing is I
don't see it as a kind of neo-marxist
postmodernist plot really I mean what I
see around me is people who think that
they are really you know making the next
advance in civil rights right for
instance I mean a lot of people seem to
think that you know certain class of
people are just disadvantaged and you
know we should sort of give them a leg
up and you know help them get to you
know the 11 the other groups and so on
right and
it really seems to come back to the
grand narrative for the last few decades
it has been that we've been identifying
various forms of oppression in our
society and then you know remedying them
right and the thing is I mean that
narrative is actually quite right in
many ways like I you know I think it was
a good thing that racial minorities got
the same civil rights I think it's a
good thing that you know we be allowed
gay marries and so on but then how do
you explain to people that their pet
causes are now mostly harmful rather
than health well that's a great question
I mean first of all if you take someone
who who's been affected let's say by
postmodern discourse and you pull them
out of their group you find that they're
a fragmentary representation of that
narrative you know it's like nobody who
professes Marxism is the full embodiment
of Marxism in order to get the full
embodiment of Marxism you need a pretty
good-sized mob and then the mob will be
possessed by the spirit of Marxism right
because all the fragments come together
and then the mob will act out the idea
and so it's certainly possible and
highly probable that and this is what I
always remember try to remember when
people have been demonstrating against
me at my public experience is that if
you remove those people from the group
context they're like 10 percent
postmodern neo-marxists a 90 percent
decent people and of course they're
motivated by all sorts of things some of
which are actually good
fewer good things than they usually
think because people are a lot darker
than they usually know you know in
spirit and orientation but it is very
very difficult to distinguish what would
you call it corrupt ideological
possession from genuine compassion let's
say and it's it it's so and it is of
course the case that equality of
opportunity is a wonderful thing to
pursue and that everyone suffers if
everyone's capacity to contribute to the
collective is somehow impeded
I don't think anybody disagrees with
that unless they're really extreme
ethnocentric types you know anything
whatever they can think whatever they
want so but I think that a in many ways
it's gone too far
and be that the motivations that are
stated as the conscious motivations are
not sufficiently differentiated there's
way more going on than meets the eye and
the reason I think that especially is
because the universities appear to have
become so corrupt being the humanities
like the disciplines are corrupt women's
studies is corrupt beyond belief to
think about Western civilization
primarily as an oppressive patriarchy
first of all that's a mythological idea
and it's a very it's a very uni
dimensional idea it's it's just not a
good idea like compared to what exactly
compared to a hypothetical ideal well
okay but compared to any other
civilization that has ever existed
anywhere well no it's it's it's it's not
going anywhere that idea so yes you
can't throw the baby out with the
bathwater
and there have been many things positive
things I would say that the left has
contributed to the political debate
workers rights for example especially in
the early 20th century that was very
very positive all things considered
and there's place for left-wing
viewpoints but not at the expense of
other viewpoints mmm absolutely that's
the thing thank you so thank you dr.
Peterson it seems as though young adults
in the West are stuck in a sense of
prolonged childhood and I'm wondering
first of all if you agree with that
statement and second of all what you
think the causes behind that might be
okay well I would say there's an unholy
conspiracy that that is propagated in
part by the universities which is that
you can come to university and extend
your adolescence
and and maintain your irresponsibility
for a socially sanctioned for your
period well we vacuum up your future
earnings okay okay so that's not good
that's not good it's a bargain with the
devil fundamentally and so there's that
and then the next thing is and I think
this is a demographic issue I mean to
the degree let's say that adolescence
has become extended well let's assume
that that's just correct for the moment
although I think you can have a
reasonable debate about that I think
there are other important reasons one
might be that parents are older and
older when they have kids
and so that makes a difference when
you're young and careless and you have
kids you're not going to hover over them
as if they're the most precious things
in the world and then maybe you only
have one kid so you're 40 and like it
was a hell of a thing to have that kid
and it's the only kid you're gonna have
and so you put all your eggs in one
basket so to speak and the probability
that because you're also older and more
conservative that you're going to be
hyper protective under the guise of
involvement is very high and then you
don't have siblings like you need
siblings to pound you out on a fairly
regular basis so that you don't so that
you understand that you're not the
center of the world and siblings are
probably better at that than anyone else
right because if you're if you're a
narcissistic among siblings like yeah
yeah good luck to you and so you know so
we know there's been dramatic changes in
the familial structure over the last
three decades and I would say older
parenting and the the smaller size of
families is our massive sociological and
psychological transformations and we
really don't know what their long-term
consequences and then I also think in
some ways it's certainly more difficult
for young people to enter adult careers
in a straightforward manner than it was
in the 60s let's say because one of the
great fears of the 60s radicals was that
they were going to have to have the same
great job for their entire life it's
like looking
it's such a ridiculous fears like that's
what you were afraid of right you were
gonna have a high-paying corporate job
that was stable and secure it's like man
the man really had you have really had
you at that point and with you guys it's
the future although rich and in
indescribable ways is also weirdly
uncertain for people say between 18 and
22 it seems like it's harder to catalyze
an identity than it was because of the
fluidity of the culture and like you
have great opportunities remarkable
opportunities but they're they're not
precisely stable in the way that they
were for quite a while after World War
two so that's what it looks like to me
anyways so thank you good evening i dr.
peterson made the argument that you have
to be allowed to be wrong in order to
learn how to be right i'd like to ask
about the flip side of that coin the
permission to be right archetypal
example of this would be lets say
galileo and my question would be what is
today's galileo something that is true
but in danger of being suppressed to
each of you care to answer that's a good
one I think the whole I mean the whole
attack on the West requires a different
worldview but it requires burying like
under mounds of Saia Iran talked about
this in regard to capitalism but I think
it's a true in regard to the whole
history of the West it needs to be
buried 10 feet underground so that
people are not aware of what actually
happened what all the arguments were I
meet someone brought up with that were
Canadians I don't think it's an accident
often immigrants have a different
perspective on the country than people
living there do and take just for
instance the First Amendment there's a
whole long intellectual history of what
led to the First Amendment that from my
experience nobody knows
what does the separation of church and
state mean I talk to American nobody can
give me any answer of what it actually
where it came from why it's in the First
Amendment why Jefferson thought this was
one of his three great achievements it
was the University of Virginia
Declaration of Independence and
separating church and state statute
religious freedoms in Virginia which is
part of the model for the First
Amendment so there's so much about the
whole the ideas that produce the West
that no no one learns in school today
and you're actively discouraged from
pursuing so there's just there's such a
tremendous amount of knowledge that I
think philosophical moral and cultural
about the West that has been lost I'll
jump off that one and say that just a
simple ability to be proud of being an
American I think is being undermined
right now I was in DC last week and I
live in LA where I'm pretty sure it's
illegal to have an American flag and you
know I was in DC and there were flags
everywhere and I actually really liked
it it didn't mean that these people were
had unbridled patriotism and we're gonna
bow down to the government all the time
I think in many cases it actually meant
that they wanted limited government and
they wanted liberty and that's why they
were proud to display the flag but that
concept that you can be proud of this
experiment of America that as I said
earlier is done more good for more
people everyone still wants to come here
and you guys looking to get out of here
anyone looking to get out of America
right now yeah nobody and the people
that hate America the most are the same
people who want us to have open borders
I guess so they can share in the horrors
of America so none of it none of the
things that they're throwing at us makes
sense and I think actually being proud
of it not blindly proud but being proud
of this incredible experiment is is it
is sort of shamed in the media in
general and it's something that I'm very
proud of I would say the closest there's
two examples that come to mind that I
think are that are reminiscent of the
Galileo experience one is the
suppression of research on psychedelics
in the late
it's not surprising it happened but but
it was a mistake in my estimation and it
was a it was a mistake that was
predicated on the same kind of fear and
then I would also say that we're in
danger of making research into the
biological basis of gender differences
let's say unpalatable and you saw that
happening with James - more like I read
James timorous memo pretty carefully and
for a non for a non biologist it's not
exactly true because he had some
biological training I mean he summarized
the literature pretty accurately and
it's really a big mistake to not attend
carefully to the actual differences
between men and women because freedom by
definition would be a state in which
those differences
that's diversity let's say where those
differences were allowed to express
themselves and maybe even celebrated and
so and I think that is happening to some
degree but those would be two areas like
I think the biologists are in real
trouble the social justice warriors are
going to go after them they're already
doing that and because the biologists if
you know anything about evolutionary
psychology evolutionary biology and and
there's plenty to know it demonstrates
quite clearly that all of the claims of
the radical social constructionists are
just wrong right it's been proven that's
why they're taking the political route
now is that they got stomped they got
stomped in the intellectual community no
reasonable scientist has entertained a
radical social constructionist view of
human beings since I would say probably
it probably started to collapse in the
early 60s but by 1980 it was like wasn't
even an issue it's like obviously there
are tremendous genetic factors that that
influence behavior and that makeup
differences between men and women not
least and so thank you
alright you know we're gonna take one
more can you give us a Big Finish you
feel good about this question yeah I
mean I can try to give you a good finish
yeah alright Big Finish here we go so
early oh yeah sorry guys we'll hang out
for a little bit after and sorry and I'm
gonna try to get drunk here later so you
guys know where to go hopefully they'll
join me early on in the talk dr. got a
you talked about the existence of public
universities being a contradiction to
the idea of the First Amendment
I guess that extends as well to just
generally public education do you think
that's an issue that solvable in the
foreseeable future or is that sort of
the final obstacle that will pass in the
in the future yeah I think it's a it's a
final issue because I think even the
founders didn't understand this issue
that so if you think of the religious
clauses and why they're formulated like
that it's the government can't interfere
with free exercise of religion that
means me in my private life if I want to
practice a particular religion it can
bend that I can wear a yarmulke or
something like that so I can't but it
can establish and that meant government
support and funding for a particular
religious viewpoint even if other people
were still allowed to practice their
other religions it was you're favoring
one giving one a leg up and you're
taking money from other people to
support ideas that they don't want to
support and then what I mean part of the
argument was when you have an
established church like that then people
want to get their hands on it and try to
control and so and it's all through
political coercive means and that is a
good argument for why you have but if
you think of it in terms of intellectual
freedom
it should pertain to the whole
intellectual world that you have free
exercise you can set up whatever schools
you want to teach what you want but the
government can't establish it can't
establish in any intellectual realm it
has no interest in promoting certain
ideas religious or secular but the
moment you
have public schools and public
universities the government has to be in
that business there's no getting around
it and then you have all kinds of
warfare about who's gonna control the
public universities in the public
schools who's gonna write the textbooks
are we going to put evolution or not in
the textbook it becomes a whole
political battle but the reason it is a
political battle because you've given
government this power to fund these
kinds of things and when the government
controls the purse strings
it controls ideas people don't recognize
that but it is in it it's the same
argument in regard to church as applies
to every intellectual each issue and
it's much more important in education I
think well thank you guys for coming out
this has been
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this is what it's all about guys so take
these ideas if you like them and fight
for whatever you believe and and let me
know where where we're going later yeah
so just just before we leave let me I've
just got a few things I want to say the
first is that like on car got a and
Jordan Peterson I too am a Canadian and
after today's event I've realized what
the biggest difference is between
Canadians and Americans namely Canadians
self set self sensor we don't swear in
public for all the students in this room
if you have enjoyed hearing the ideas
that you've heard today if you are
interested in an education that uses a
great books approach to studying the
history of liberty capitalism the
American Founding and the principles of
moral character please come and see us
at the clemson institute for the study
of capitalism we're in 329 serene hall
and i'd love to meet with any of you
students the next thing i want to say is
that for again for all the students who
are here today i am really happy for you
I really am Anand and the reason I'm
happy for you is because you've just had
the experience of witnessing three
really great minds and you've had the
opportunity to see great minds at work
as they think out loud and that's a very
rare opportunity and I'm delighted that
we've been able to provide that for you
and just once again I'd like you to all
join me in giving yet again another
rousing Clemson thank you
[Applause]
[Music]